O
YOU.
WE HAVE TO QUICKLY GO AND CHECK
IN.
I KNOW YOU HAD TO RUSH INSIDE
MOMENTS AGO.
WHAT'S HAPPENING THERE?
>> GUNFIRE IS ERUPTING ACROSS
KYIV AT THIS MOMENT.
OFF IN THE DISTANCE, WE HEARD
GUNFIRE AND EXPLOSIONS AROUND
THE CENTRAL PART OF THIS CAPITAL
CITY.
A FEW MONTHS AGO, GUNFIRE
STARTED COMING FROM ALL
DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS, SO WE HAD
TO MOVE INSIDE QUICKLY.
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF TRACER
ROUNDS YOU COULD SEE IN THE
DISTANCE.
THIS IS WIDESPREAD IN THE CITY.
IT'S NOT JUST ONE LOCATION WHERE
THERE ARE UKRAINIAN TROOPS --
WARNED OF THIS SCENARIO,
BASICALLY SAYING THAT TONIGHT
WOULD BE WHAT DECIDES THE STATE
OF UKRAINE.
CLEARLY, THE RUSSIANS ARE FACING
CLEAR RESISTANCE IN THE STREETS
OF KYIV, AND THE GUNFIRE
CONTINUES INSIDE THE CITY
LIMITS.
OUTSIDE, THERE ARE REPORTS OF
MORE RUSSIAN TROOPS MAKING THEIR
WAY TO THE UKRAINIAN CAPITAL.
ATTACKING UKRAINE FROM MULTIPLE
DIRECTIONS AND THE CITY.
IT'S NOT JUST KYIV, WHERE THERE
IS RENEWED VIOLENCE TAKING
PLACE.
ALSO -- THE SECOND LARGEST
UKRAINIAN CITY TAKING FIRE
ACCORDING TO REPORTS.
WE ARE GOING TO LIMIT WHAT WE
SAY ABOUT THE UKRAINIAN AND
RUSSIAN SIDE TONIGHT IN TERMS OF
STATEMENTS ABOUT DIFFERENT
ACCUSATIONS MADE BY BOTH SIDES.
REPORTS OF PLANES BEING SHOT
DOWN AND THOUGHT ALIKE.
WE WANT TO HOLD OFF ON THIS
INFORMATION, BECAUSE THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS FLYING AROUND
TONIGHT.
WHAT WE CAN REPORT IS WHAT WE
CAN SEE AND WHAT WE -- THERE ARE
RUSSIAN TROOPS INSIDE OF THE
UKRAINIAN CAPITAL OF KYIV AT
THIS MOMENT.
IT'S A WORST-CASE SCENARIO FOR
THE UKRAINIAN FORCES, BUT
RUSSIAN TROOPS ARE FACED WITH
DIFFICULTIES AHEAD, ACCORDING TO
THE PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE TALKED
TO.
EVERYONE WOULD TALK TO FOR
MEMBERS OF PARLIAMENT -- THEY
WILL NOT ALLOW THE RUSSIANS TO
OCCUPY.
>> THE PRESIDENT MADE
SPEAKER OF THE PRESIDENT MADE IT
CLEAR IT MAY BE THE LAST TIME HE
SPEAKS TO HIS PEOPLE BECAUSE HE
BELIEVES HIS TARGET NUMBER ONE.
HE THOUGHT HIS FAMILY AS TARGET
NUMBER TWO.
WE ARE SHOWING THE VIDEO NOW.
HE IS ON THE MOVE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE HE IS.
OBVIOUSLY HE WANTS TO KEEP SAFE
BUT ALSO HE'S NOT LEAVING THE
COUNTRY.
SOME SO-CALLED LEADERS HAVE
ABANDONED LAYERS, AS WE SAW IN
AFGHANISTAN.
IN A SENSE OF HIS ABILITY TO
RALLY THE PEOPLE AT THIS HOUR?
>> HE IS TRYING THE HARDEST TO
RALLY HIS PEOPLE, SPEAKING
DIRECTLY TO THE POPULATION
SAYING THAT THEY MUST RESIST THE
RUSSIANS.
THE DIFFICULT PART HERE IS THAT
RUSSIA COMES TO THIS BATTLE WITH
AIRPOWER AND GROUND POWER THAT
THE UKRAINIANS EARLY ON WILL BE
ABLE TO PUSH BACK AND WE HAVE
SEEN THAT IN THE EARLY HOURS OF
THIS FIGHT.
BUT IT IS NOT SUSTAINABLE.
IT'S PART OF THE REASON THAT YOU
SAW UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY APPEALING TO
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY AND
PLEADING WITH HIM TO SEND
WEAPONS TO THIS COUNTRY.
YESTERDAY YOU HAD THE NATO
SECRETARY GENERAL JAN SULTAN SAG
THAT THERE WOULD BE AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEMS DELIVERED TO UKRAINE.
THE BIG QUESTION IS HOW.
THERE IS NO AIR TRAVEL IN THE
COUNTRY.
MARTIAL LAW IS DECLARED BECAUSE
FIGHTING IS ERUPTING IN THE
STREETS OF THE CAPITAL AND IT'S
TOO LATE, REALLY.
THIS BATTLE WILL LIKELY
CONTINUE.
YOU CAN HEAR IT.
>> THE FIRST THING YOU DO IS
TAKE THE AIRPORTS AND THEY
SECURE THE AIRPORT